欢迎收听古爱,我是星梦公
本期节目由善存益生菌赞助
三餐常常外食,吃饭配工作
会担心消化到机能吗?
益生菌白白种,常常不知道怎么选哪一款益生菌最有效吗?
善存三酵顺畅益生菌
添加凤梨酵素,顺畅消化,好体质一包三酵
善存70年专业品牌
这款三酵顺畅益生菌
双专利益生菌搭配凤梨酵素
帮助你养出消化到好环境
双专利益生菌
让你代谢顺畅大大干净
维持健康
人自然年轻
还有添加凤梨酵素
加速分解蛋白质
消化更有感
有效才敢推荐给你
那另外
善存还有舒眠益生菌
食品及直萃成分
拥有五大晚安因子
添加专利舒眠番红花
多国专利益生菌
Gaba
芝麻素
色胺酸等
可以帮助放松好入睡
让你天天吃好安心
想睡就睡
睡醒精神好
好菌天天吃
养成好体质
天天精神好
投资财富
靠自己投資健康就讓善存來幫你
9月19-9月30號善存古來秘密賣場
限折200折價券加碼送棉花糖枕頭收納包
有些人朋友在我們資訊欄這邊找到更多的說明與連結
好那我的首次出差之旅算是畫上一個完美的句點
我覺得我應該會記蠻久的
我覺得是一個非常有趣的體驗
那首先在行錢的各種規劃上就已經覺得蠻好玩的
那時候是在看牧章附近的飯店
然後也有在節目跟大家分享
其實我發現這附近並沒有好的飯店
所以本來有在糾結說
是不是要往東京住
然後記得通勤過來
但是在地有人說電玩展會大爆炸
所以如果說你要坐車進來
你會搞到自己非常的辛苦
就算你是坐計程車
也可能遇到塞車的問題之類的
所以最後面想一想就決定
好啦反正就是住在旁邊就好
那只是最後發現我自己的通勤友人
他們都還是住在東京比較靠市區的地方
他們是通勤進來
就是互相羨慕啦
我就說你們那邊感覺比較好玩
然後我說你這邊好近喔
確實是超級近的
我之後就選擇一家叫做木樟心大谷的
我只要過一條馬路就到了
超級無敵性
所以像我們有些東西就會直接丟到房間
因為非常非常的方便
飯店整體的素質跟水平也都蠻好的
其實就是符合日本人他們的
各式各樣的評價的一些小drama
反正簡單來說說他不會給你太高的評價
所以當我看到那個評價的分數是這樣
我還想說這個地方會不會是個雷
但想說反正來都來了
我就是來工作的
所以也不要想太多
最終發現說這個飯店是還蠻不錯的
雖然一開始差一點出包
簡單來講是因為那時候是
使用Agoda去訂房
到這邊飯店人員就跟我說
你的房間是吸煙房我說他媽為什麼是吸煙房給他看我Agoda我剛剛說我上面名句寫說是Non-smoking他說你這個是request你這個是要求的訂單那並不是說確定的訂單
你只是要求說你要non smoking
可是我們沒有non smoking
那時候心中就立刻量一半
所以我就趕快
反正出包了
那就立刻去做補救
問他說你有沒有大一點的房間
你就直接把我升到你最好的房間去
他說可是大一點的房間還是是吸煙房
那時候心中就閃過無數個念頭
然後最後面覺得
好啦好啦反正來都來了
就這樣吧
以前也不是他們沒有在網咖睡覺過
日本的吸煙房可能就很像網咖
只是我覺得比較嚴重
就是有一些比較小的飯店
你會注意到他們的一些什麼塑膠panel
不然說像什麼冷氣的
牆上的控制器
或是一些排風口
就會很噁心
就像是那種土黃色
煙椒油罵長期燻的那種感覺
就想說反正來都來了
好啦你就還是幫我升到比較大的房間
比較大的房間可能至少就是相對通風吧
我是忘記說我房間零多少錢
可是光是升級房間
就在額外付了好像15萬日元出去
最後面在走廊上的時候
我心裡就非常猶豫
因為一到這個樓層
靠北就是那種網咖的煙味
然後想說這到底是什麼鬼
還要一進房間
就是我的猜測是對的
比較大的房間就是沒有煙味
可能這一間就剛好大家進來都不會抽煙之類
還是說它真的就是散的比較快
大房間有自己的客廳
然後兩張床
又可以泡澡什麼東西都有
真的是蠻大的一間空間
就沒有聞到太多煙味
所以在住宿這方面算是
終於是安心的
出發前我也準備了名片
因為我自己是沒有名片這種東西
上次去Startup Sphere的活動的時候
人家要換名片我都沒有名片
有些團隊是想要認識我們
我就說你去上網Google
我們就找到信箱
我後來發現說這樣是一個
可能比較不禮貌的事情
所以一定要準備名片
於是就跑去印名片
只是我自己想要的名片是那一種
我沒有要搞到很華僑
但是我就想要低調奢華的一個味道
所以我第一個想到就是American Cycle
就那個美國殺人魔那一部
Patrick Bateman也就是蝙蝠俠那個演員
一時間忘記他叫什麼
反正總之這位演員
他就是把一個就是psychopath
sociopath演得非常的好
他後面看到了Gerrett Latto的名片
他覺得說這個人的名片做得太好
他就很嫉妒
一直看一直冒冷
人家問他說你怎麼了
然後反正就把這個人殺掉
很北來就有一幕是他們在比較名片
他們的名片都是長得蠻類似的
跟這細節上的一些差距
也演出說這些人到底是多有病
反正就是白底黑字
所以我就覺得說就是要白底黑字要低調奢華可能要用比較好的紙之類的再來要燙黑 壓凹什麼的這就是我心中想法的名片只是要做出我要的名片是沒有辦法在東京電玩展前完成的
所以我就還是要我想要的名片
但是你可不可以給我一個緊急備用的
所以就直接用一個印刷的版本
當然紙也是故意選那種相對高一點幫速
就覺得說要讓自己舒服
自己看了要喜歡
就是名片也準備好
飯店也OK
所以就直接去挑戰電玩展
那也非常感謝帶路的一些朋友
還有幫我們搞到正的一些朋友
整體的體驗是非常好
因為有上網看到人家說
什麼光是排隊進場就可以搞到崩潰
讓他們在那邊拉人龍
就日本喜歡搞什麼那種
什麼整理券那種玩法
就是叫你們去那邊排隊
然後大家都超喜歡排隊的
也都蠻守規矩的
但就覺得說就很瘋
就什麼都要排隊或什麼的
我們拿到這個特殊票券
就可以快一點進場了
所以畢竟我們也是在談生意的
也不是說什麼單純的亂逛
所以有這樣子的福利也是挺好的
可以立刻的去接觸到自己有興趣的團隊
或是好玩的東西
看了一些比較大的場館
就是裡面都是那種知名IPR大的
那個我就覺得說
並沒有覺得印象特別的深刻
因為簡單來講就是說
遊戲這種東西本來就是你在家裡
就可以直接下載demo或是一些影片來看
所以你到現場去除非你是炮哥
就是你要去拍那種showgirl
不然他們也沒有準備太多的周邊的東西
在那邊跟大家互動
只有少數幾個
像洛克人那一攤他有準備一些東西
蠻多其實就只是把東西展出來給你看
其實你在家都可以自己玩到
所以簡單講說可能是像去看人
如果說真的是用展會來說
我覺得電腦展比較好玩
電腦展真的比較好玩
再稍微的看了一下這些比較大的IP
跟廠商之後
然後當然就是進入我們的主軸去看
這些indie games
也接觸到了
有在信箱中跟我們聯繫的日本團隊
雖然是日本團隊
但是他們的成員幾乎都是各地的外國人
他們只在日本去成立他的studio
完成這個指定的任務之後
接下來就是到處的去看團隊
在這兩天
注意到蠻多有趣的遊戲
也發現了他們的痛點
蠻多都在表示說
他們現在其實是需要一個優質的發行商加行銷
蠻多人都有類似的一個痛點
剛好我們校男是可以去滿足這個問題的
或是我們可以去協助做處理
簡單來說
我們幫自己的定位就是
我們不是只是掏錢來支持
我們掏錢加不會有太多廢話不會想要拐你不會想要跟你要一堆CART同時可能還可以幫你解決你不擅長處理的一些法務或是說簽約 以及發行行銷什麼的
我們都是有相關的股東是可以去處理這些事情的
所以跟這些團隊也算是相談甚歡
就是走到他們的攤位上
不管是用keyboard mouse
還是用PlayStation跟Xbox的手把去玩他們的遊戲
我覺得就是我自己看上的機款遊戲
果然就是跟Anthony Brodine說的一樣
如果你注意到一個東西看起來好吃
你就吃就對了
看起來好玩你就玩
最後面自己有一個小小的心得
這沒有diss或是吐槽任何人的意思
可是我就發現說
有些攤位搞得比較盛大的
可能前面有showgirl
然後跟一些coaster會發東西
或是有罵一排都穿制服五個人
然後在那邊給你傳單
I got the mask 什麼這種
一般都不好玩
就是一般都不好玩
我自己的體驗是這樣
反而是那些看起來罰人問津的
或是罵跟三個宅男在那邊排隊
在那邊打遊戲
負責人很認真在那邊介紹的
就看起來有點破的那些
蠻多都還蠻有趣的
有注意到這個一個小現象
也不是說那些花錢的想法
自己弄好的人就是
不會創作遊戲或什麼的
反正就是一個覺得蠻有趣的觀察
稍微的說一下
有很多款遊戲都很棒
有認識到一款是來自於西班牙的
我還跟他說
我老婆也是西班牙阿里坎特來的
然後就直接就聊上線了
然後交換一些聯絡方式
覺得他們的遊戲真的都是做的還蠻不錯的
也不知道說這個校南有沒有機會
就開始去投一些海外的團隊
當然我們還是聚焦台灣的團隊為主
只是我們發現說
我們最後面匯聚出來的力量跟資金的量體
其實我們是可以往海外去進攻的
所以也就是稍微的看了一些這些海外的團隊
當然後面有蠻多東西要去思考
不然說投後管理要怎麼樣做
然後再來就是
可能會先盡量的去集中一些portfolio
在至少去亞洲區
管理比較方便
後面如果說可以進歐洲去的話
再看我們的hub可能要弄在哪裡
要怎麼樣去做處理之類
但我們現在是真的有接觸到那種
可能一些在歐洲甚至美洲的團隊
這個是蠻令人意外的
看下來覺得充滿了生命力
這些新創的遊戲團隊開發者
不知道怎麼去跟他們講話
就覺得很高興
就覺得說這些人真的在燃燒自己的熱血跟生命
然後在做一個可能自己覺得很酷的事情
他可能也是跟我一樣
就是小時候喜歡打遊戲
只是我們選擇了不一樣的道路
我就是比較世俗
我跑去賺錢
也不是他們不賺錢
我的意思是說
就是他們就選擇了一個
可能是
Stake is bigger
他們賭比較大
玩比較大
但希望說
我們有機會可以去協助他們
不管是單純的
就是一個消費者
所以那些不錯的遊戲
我都把它加入Game List
就像Wish List裡面
我就是一定會去玩它
也希望說
就是孝楠可以去參與
他們的一個成長
這個是心中的一些規劃
再來也跟自己的一些股東們
因為我們的股東
其實就是來自各方
然後他們有些
也是來東京電玩展
去談另類的生意
就是跟遊戲不一定是相關的
可能一些周邊
我就有點像是說
反正就是take alone就跟著
然後看人家開會講什麼就坐在旁邊
然後交換名片
我就覺得這個其實蠻有趣的過程
你好
然後我的名片給你
其實換了之後好像也不能夠幹嘛
但不知道
這個就是可能是商務旅行的一個真諦
就是大家都帶一堆名片
然後在那邊交換來交換去
所以我現在一看
就有桌上一堆名片
也不知道怎麼樣去做實用
因為已經很習慣於說
其實我覺得我們自己算是
比較幸運的一個存在
那種得天獨厚的感覺
因為自己在台灣也算是一個小名人
所以其實有蠻多很好的project
就是我們根本就不用動
他們就自己味到我們的面前
所以我們在Dial sourcing這部分
已經有一定程度的優勢
跑來東西電玩展就是人生地不熟
所以就會有那種陌生開發的一個滋味
就會感受到說你這個名片遞出去
其實你也不一定會有什麼結果
但就交朋友
這個是我平常不會做的
因為我下去已經密底瓜康
我就是只想縮腳
跟我不想認識任何人
可是為了校男
為了台灣的遊戲
或是為了我們的Portfolio
我要做的事情就是我要去認識大家
所以我就是時常的掛上我的微笑
然後跟大家換名片
其實也是看到了蠻多有趣的畫面
聽大家在那邊開會也是覺得蠻玩的
即便他不一定跟我的業務相關
所以簡單來說
商務之旅是有趣的
雖然可能蠻多那種很常要出差的
一定心頭講說
媽的你是因為第一次你很新鮮
你才覺得好玩
對我相信
就如果說這個是變成
我每個月都要去一次的東西
我說不定就不會喜歡了
但久久一次是蠻喜歡的
下次還會說服老婆說
我還是要再去
大概這樣子
那這邊有一個我覺得
蠻好笑的事情
就是我在我的
古埃哥的臉書上面
然後就轉貼了一篇WCCF Tech
他所提到AMD要去轉價
他可能在健原代光這邊
被TSMC漲了10%
然後把這個價格轉出去
那就如既往
就是我的做法會稍微的短評一下我的短頻其實我自己有發現就是它比較偏向是是有些人會把衝回是意識流下面的聽眾所寫的我就看到漫報的Many
他在下面就寫到說
再給我發展個五年的話
我的這些點評可能會變成是
某一種籤詩題
下面有另外一個聽眾就寫到說
很有趣的是我的節目
可能是講得非常的直白
可是看我的寫的內容
會比較偏向是
好像我就是意識流
我就是把想到的東西寫出來
我也不在意大家看不看得懂
真的是這樣 恭喜答對
但是我並不是說不在意
就是I don't care
I don't give a shit about you
不是這樣子
他有點像是說
最早我當然也會想把事情講清楚
只是後來就
因為真的沒有那麼多美國時間
在節目裡面已經是需要去把蠻多東西
起承轉合給好好說好
所以我們的貼文其實已經變成是
某個成績出來的答案好了
對我來說是一種答案好了
就是我其實不太在意
最大多數的一般聽眾
你聽不聽得懂
我只在意可能看得懂一些關鍵字的人
你會不會就我所貼出的情報
然後來跟我去做一些討論
所以它是一個特化的結果
看起來可能對有些人來說會像天書
就像是即便我們節目已經相對講的很淺白了
可是你很常在QA看到聽眾講說什麼
聽了一兩年聽不懂
然後終於可能第三年才開始聽懂之類的
那沒有辦法那就是一種專業
我們已經盡量的去
用相對直白的方式去跟大家講
只是說如果每一集
我們都要類似一些科普頻道
要跟你講起程轉合的話
那沒關沒了
這個是沒有辦法的
所以還是要以我的工作做一個核心
也就是股市的交易
所以對我來說
獲取情報可能是最重要的東西
如果意外的讓大家可以有一些收穫
那就太好了
但其實沒有辦法去顧及到
每個人的可能水準不同
然後可以了解到的東西是怎麼樣
所以就來說
如果這一篇文要把它拉到節目上講的話
就要先定義清楚
這個漲價的人是誰
TSMC漲多少10%
消息是不是真的
也可以討論一下
接著漲的對象是誰
AMD
當然不會只有漲AMD
如果要漲的話一定是大家都漲
其實市場已經有在傳說
就是在明年可能我們最大的Fundry
他就是有機會會去做漲價
非常合理
因為畢竟就像是Jensen自己講
他也覺得台積電的價格是太便宜
CCWay也自己提到說
這些機器廠長得真實施壓羨慕
但是他還是要跟客戶共同成長
不過我們都知道說
如果說真的很缺的話
這個價格去做一些調整
去反映一些成本
其實都是一個非常合理的操作
接著可能就會去探討說
AMD被漲的產品是什麼
就開始切
是CPU還是GPU
就每個東西都要去做討論
結果我的文章竟然不是這樣寫我是直接媽跳針開頭直接講說AMSRP的參考價值不高這句話的意思是什麼就是說因為AMSRP就是一個標準售價它只是你在過去你知道各種components都在漲價
你說一個板卡上面有的東西
其實不是只有上面的man chip
或是說GDR在漲價
一些相關的像是被動元件
其實大家的價格都跟著跑
甚至裡面的這個板子
這個價格也都有跟著上去
甚至suck it都有在動
所以這些東西因為都在漲價
那MSRP不一定會及時跟著調整
反應在消費者這邊所看到的
就是我有看到漲價
可是我好像沒有看到
NVIDIA好像AMD這樣子
對外宣布
或是說有消息傳出來說我要去漲價
為什麼
那就是我後面寫的那一段
因為NVIDIA的賣法是怎麼樣
它是一個set一起出去
也就是我的GPU可能是搭載著GDDR
這一包我是一個set賣出去給下游的AIC
這主要在定義
AIC是什麼意思
我就再寫一下
如果要認真寫會是這樣
AIC這邊我收到的東西是漲價的
我當然就會把它反映到終端
讓客人知道說
其實它實際的價格是怎樣
是往上跑的
所以即便NVIDIA它並沒有對外宣布
或是沒有 rumor跑出來
但大家所看到的價格就是往上跑的
所以第一段就變成這樣
可是想說這個文章明明就在寫AMD
為什麼我要先講到NVIDIA
因為我覺得NVIDIA的顯示卡漲價
才是最重要的一個環節
所以就算這一篇明明就在寫AMD
可是我就會覺得說
我要先去講這個NVIDIA這一段
然後接著才帶到AMD
我也懶得去定義說到底是哪一條產品
因為反而它就是一個 rumor
我們在市場裡面去處理 rumor的時候
有時候要帶有一點藝術性的
甚至要看當下的盤面去做一個決定
接著就稍微提一下說
其實AMD的漲價
就像他感覺是寫出來
你看就是因為金融代工廠漲價
所以什麼漲價
但大家可能要注意的是
漲最多的一個factor
其實就是記憶體
其實最主要就是記憶體
所以我就會認為說
你把這個金融代工廠寫出來
就是一個那種類似說
像他漲價 民怨四起
所以你看TSMC在講他還背鍋
但不是他只是一個尾刀的角色
所以如果我就把它做詳細的說明
可能大家就比較可以理解
但這個並不是我特別專業的部分
可能在節目裡面可以
但寫文章其實後來都是盡量用這種
類似意識流的方式
我就把一些關鍵的key facts丟出來
也不在意說到底大家看不看得懂
但是看得懂一定看得懂
因為我就是用這樣子
然後持續的去拿到我要的情報
所以我就覺得說我這樣做就對了
我覺得Many是非常厲害的
因為像是在漫報裡面
他們最近也寫到Daryl Modi的那一篇
就是說We must pace the frontier labs
我忘記那個標題什麼
大概是這樣
就我們上集所聊到的內容我們算是一個非常線性的這樣講下去可是Manier他就先把問題定義得非常清楚請問你講的Paste the Frontier到底是哪一種是哪三種哪三種速度需要被做線索
我想說你怎麼可以想到這三種東西
其實很多時候就像是我去看到一些實際
我覺得超了不起
就是為什麼這些人去寫實際
可以寫到說這個人以前是師承誰
他從哪裡出來
他拿到的餘生的等級是怎麼樣
他的握法又是跟誰是怎麼樣
然後大將所準備出來的東西
他的酒窯跟哪一家很像
我想說你們怎麼這麼多內心戲
你講的東西我全部也都吃過
而且我也吃了好幾輪了
我就沒有辦法
怎麼講就吃東西
你畫怎麼那麼多
但我不是說那些很認真寫的畫很多
我意思是說你怎麼那麼厲害
你怎麼可以想到要這樣子寫
然後會讓很多人很有帶入感
所以我覺得那是一種天分
有些人真的是非常會用文字寫東西
那我不會 我就用聊的
反正總之就是
那篇文章的內容
我也是試著要去獲得一些產業情報
我簡單講就是我做的每一個貼文
我都會有想要知道的事情
有時候就會透過一些關鍵資訊所提到的內容
就會拿到我要的東西
所以再隨便去舉一個例子
我現在如果在這邊
我想說CCL的降歸事件
這個對於很多人來說是
好 那我接下來想要聽你說什麼
但對於我們圈子內的人
聽到這邊就會知道說
就是上個禮拜
某個地方大德在某個地方論壇
發表了某個言論
導致盤中一堆東西跳水
然後接著就超多人跑出來幹
還有些人拿美國隊長的名音出來做圖
還有些人開始寫文章
還有些人會拿萬年梗
就是什麼在巴士上面看到誰坐在哪裡
反正就是我們圈子裡面
人會知道的東西
然後大家拿出來批鬥
然後互相開始嘴炮
接著有一些外資的勸章發了反擊文
那有一些認同的人或什麼的
就是這短短的一句話
CCL的降規
你看如果你是在圈子裡面的
突然間資訊就爆了
就是你腦中就有抄東西出來
可是對於不是這個圈子內的
像我們蠻多聽眾在健身的時候聽
你想說
所以你要不要跟我講到底發生什麼事
對當然有時候我不用講發生什麼事
我只要講這個事件
那我怎麼看
結束
就是我也不用跟你講起床轉合
可是我就已經把我要的東西穿搭完成了
然後接著
收的人知道的
他也可能就是有辦法來跟我做討論
所以大概是這樣
但我們還是可以稍微的來
討論一下這個事件
因為這個其實是跟在過去一陣子
供應鏈上發生的各種事情
是蠻有關係的
今天來講就是現在在整個
AI的供應鏈上有超多
所以他們就會開始去思考很多
alternative solution
所以就來說像我們過去的集中跟大家聊說
這個記憶體也開始有廠家去討論說
我們或許不要一直積極的去往更高的疊層
更高的high數去跑
可能就是8high或甚至是4high就好
4high這個我是看Trendforce
最近一個文章出來寫說
他覺得這個用在Edge device可以
可是在AI伺服器是比較難
但是在美國這邊的某些分析團體
他們就是有提到說應該會往這個方向去跑
那像這個東西為什麼會有一個這樣子的討論出來
最主要原因還是因為記憶體缺貨
大家想要拿到更多的記憶體
就會開始去思考說或許
因為頻寬是最重要的東西
容量也很重要
但是容量我們現在可能有一些方式
可以把它offload到外面的東西去
就是我可能不用全部東西都疊在HBM裡面
我可能可以跑到旁邊的DRAM
或甚至外面的Storage Rack
或者說可以去植用CPU的各種存儲
這個是在業界是蠻多討論的東西
所以我就是有可能
就是透過把這個high數的降低
我不要跌這麼多層
量率可以變高一點
價格可以變低一點
那我就可以順了
這個是一個很直覺的想像
但是我們那時候有跟大家聊說
這個東西沒有那麼單純的原因
是因為你可能還是需要這麼多的一個容量
那你要怎麼樣去解決這個容量的問題
你可能就是多放幾顆
多放幾顆你是不是就會用到更多的板材
所以有可能就是缺貨的東西
會從一個東西變到另外一個東西
你的頭痛一頭腳痛一腳
然後之後發現可能全身都還是不太舒服
所以目前在產業鏈上
因為就是有很多這種低Spec的東西開始出來
大家開始認為說Power不一定要用到這麼好
最近在CSP的一些朋友們就有提到說
Power Rec可能沒有必要在這麼快就上線
因為可能注意到本來目標的Rubin的功耗不會到那麼高
那時候我們可能在
應該是甚至一兩年前在聊那個Spec的時候
提到說它應該是會把它開到最高的功耗
那個是理論上是想要這樣子做
但是最終就發現說可能沒有要到那麼高
那是不是我PowerRack的一個更換的需求
就沒有這麼的急迫
記憶體如果說我想要去省錢
我想要讓它快一點的話
我就沒有這麼快的
想要去往更高規格的方向去升級
然後再來像它這個板材的鬼故事
其實也是一樣的道理
它意思就是說高速訊號在晶片旁邊
就直接轉光了
這樣子主機板是不是就只剩下
低速控制訊號
所以怎樣 我用M4就夠了
這個東西是非常有爭議的就是說你這個東西講出來就會讓蠻多人直接去想像說之前都已經講到M8 M9講說各種什麼夾乘板用什麼不同的材料去把它弄在一起
要用什麼時音PTFE什麼的
大家都已經去做那個夢了
就突然間會想說
什麼只要M4就可以
所以會導致怎樣
就是材料持續升級
ASP持續提高
這個蓄勢就會立刻的被瓦解掉
所以市場就出現一些恐慌大逃殺
但實際上是這樣嗎
我覺得不一定
因為CPU它理論上消除掉了什麼
就是ASIC到面板可插拔的光模組籠
或者說ASIC到背板中板的長距的走線
這個東西是有機會去把它消弭掉
或者說去解決
但是問題是什麼
就C2G咧
CPU到GPU的PCIe Gen6 Gen7
CX9的NIC或者CXL存儲
他們全部都是還是跑在蠻高規格的速度裡面去
所以如果你只用M4
就是10到25G的速度的材料
是跑不太動的
這個其實你在一些板材廠
他們也有提到
如果要去導入什麼PCIe Gen6的話
你的材料就要從M6升到M7之類的
所以它給的是一個大方向
就類似說可能前面開始有些人在傳說
記憶體我不用抵到那麼高
我就用4HIGH就好
那是一個方向
那是一個思考的方向
沒錯 只是最後面會這樣嗎
不一定 我覺得也不會發生
就是說可能在一些環節會出現
可是它不會是一個那種全面的現象
因為科技最終就是會持續的進步
這有時候有點像是說
因為現在缺貨
因為現在通膨在科技
至少在AI裡面是這樣子
價格高漲
所以大家就會去找出一些
在非常時期的一些手段
開始去思考說有沒有什麼其他的
alternative solution
但是這些東西
它其實對於市場的影響會是大的
就是我本來的想法是這樣子
我每次去聊之類的話題
我都會去稍微講一個淡書
就是即便他有去做dispack
在某些環節
可是它用量其實持續放大
像我抱歉說
前面所提到什麼800V有機會會遞延
這也是某個程度上
在一些人的眼中是低Spec
因為你本來在某一代要用
就像跟我說要遞延
但在我的角度是
我覺得可能也是因為年紀增長
然後部位也越做越長
就會覺得反正你終究是要往這個地方去
所以我也懶得在過程之中
先sell the rumor
然後接著可能等到某個低點買回來
因為不一定有時候是那個東西不一定會跌
或是它跌兩根之後
就直接好幾根就拉上去
這個在過去就像說現在那些板財場
就是發生過好幾次
他在過程中一直有那種鬼故事跑出來可是每次鬼故事都在很短的時間就被擊敗了只是你有沒有必要去Trade這個鬼故事所以你在市場上會看到就是這個圈子裡面的人
他們可能會吵個不可開交
因為短期就會出現一些大逃殺
或是有時候也不一定是很短
跑到中期去
就像說像那時候的氣銅轉光
把很多銅相關的類股都打爆
一堆人出來那邊踩落水狗
只是後來那些銅相關的東西
一堆都噴回去新高
就證明說
其實根本當下就不是這樣的一個情形
所以一樣的道理就是
你現在看到的所謂的CCL降規
或是記憶體的降規
PowerRack的一個降規
它們某個程度上都可能只是一個
短期的事情而已
因為終究來說
隨著你的運算效率是越來越好
東西越來越強大
材料就是一定會持續的去往上迭代
然後外加
如果你直接用這種超級簡單的論述說
因為你的高速訊號在晶片旁邊
就直接轉光就出去了
所以你整個板子比方好的話
你無法去解釋
因為你只講了一段
你沒有講到其他段
就是裡面的板上的各種元件
他們都還是要去做互動
隨著東西越來越厲害
速度越來越快
它就會去產生
在這個材料部分
如果沒有跟上的話
那就會導致這個訊號的蔑失
所以這個在市場上
我覺得比較傾向自己一種
就是短期的話題
短期的利空
然後可能會對盤面造成一個衝擊
但它並不是在長期
就是說我們就不用用那些東西
類似說前陣子
你注意到很多光通在回檔的時候
那時候不是很多人講說
所以現在是這樣
現在伺服器之間已經不用連接了是不是
當然是很多去做股票的人
會這樣去調侃自己
只是後來你看到一堆光的東西
特別是在7月的修正之後
就跑第一棒
我直接就衝出去了
那又變成說怎樣
現在光又變很香了
所以你會發現這個短期的一些變化
它會對很多人的部位造成巨大的影響
因為它看的超級短
所以它就會因為這些rumor
受到一些打擊跟影響
或是它槓桿開太大
所以就算它不想看這麼短
但是它的部位也會被洗到
所以這也是最近的一個課題
其實這個盤面
你注意到說有超多人在過去的
可能一兩個禮拜轉空
你就注意到有很多在網上分享
他們都轉空 全面轉空
這個其實是一個蠻奇怪的事情
為什麼 因為大盤在新高附近
大盤在新高附近
它根本沒有掉下來
你說好 7月的時候你轉空
還算合理
因為至少大家看到東西是掉下來的
你這個地方要喊空
好像是不是真的要警覺要擔心
我們真的也會這樣
你注意到一些東西開始目前要亂崩的話你真的會比較有警覺問題是大盤的新高附近怎麼轉空因為一堆人手上的部位就是今天突破一根明天就把你跌破然後接著它在稍微的小破底之後
又再拉上去
所以你可能拉一個月看
它是越電越高
它其實上去的
可是你每天在盯盤的人
它的鏡子一直往下跑
甚至有聽到一些
不是我們第一層的朋友圈
那朋友的朋友說什麼在做動能的
可能在過去的一段時間
已經跌破7月的低點
我想說你要怎麼樣跌破7月的低點
他想說因為每天看到強勢的追進去
隔天沒有辦法開高又丟
一直這樣搞 搞個幾輪之後錢就不借了
這個真的要小心
就是說在這種盤面
我把它稱為是比較沒有連續性
然後或是說在過去的一陣子來說
它是比較短期的一個現象
但我前陣子看到財報狗的Jeff
因為他年紀就是比較大
所以他看的比我長
我剛剛想說要怎麼樣講
才不會講說人家年紀比較大
這好像有點冒犯
但他就講到說其實這個
以他在股票裡面的經驗來講
這種所謂的沒有連續性的盤
比較扭的盤其實是常態
在過去一陣子這個不是常態
但是在我的世界觀裡面
就是我加入市場的快要一半
就是這種超級熱鬧的盤
所以我會覺得那個叫常態
我覺得說現在盤好難做
這個沒有連續性
但這個可能是正常的樣子
所以其實就是趁現在好好的習慣一下
我相信等到AI大草稍微告一個段落的時候
就會有更長的一段時間
可能會是長這個樣子
所以如果說你過度的去聚焦一些非常短線的東西
包含說這個東西的什麼
它可能又要取消它又要delay
這個在市場上超常發生的
其實從最早那種GB200
那時候節目不是會聊到說
怎麼有人喊到什麼7萬多REX
那根本就不可能達成數字
可是它在上漲的時候大家就會開始
3萬REX 5萬REX 7萬REX越喊越高
然後接著下來的時候自己在那邊修正
砍單了啦 低延了啦什麼5萬 4萬
可是問題是
如果真的很認真去研究說
不是從頭到尾就是2萬嗎
那個上去的數字是你們在吵的時候
自己喊上去
然後自己就把它喊下來
就一樣的道理
所以我對這件事情的評價是
我認為它就是類似在trade的一個
還在研究中
或是還在發展中的
某種roll map裡面的東西
然後接著可能因為一些成本的因素
或是供應來不及之類的
那或是它想要快點上
所以導致有些東西
它沒有在大家想像的那個時間點出現
所以大家就瘋狂的去sell這個東西
但最終它還是出現
然後它再次出現的時候
可能又會再上去
所以就看你是要聚焦怎麼樣的一個市場
非常短期還是長期
完全是看個人的自己的交易周期
所以那一天因為我是在電玩展
然後就看到盤中超多人
有些人在咒罵 有些人在幹狗說
亂講或什麼的
我覺得理性上來看會知道說對啦沒錯
他這樣說也不能夠說他錯
確實是會
如果說我可以在這邊就解決掉一些訊號的問題的話
我或許在短期內的材料升級
就沒有這麼的窘迫
窘迫嘛
你這樣說就可能是比較中性
比較neutral
大家也會覺得是可以認同
但如果突然間丟一個那種殺手劑出來
類似那種前面海外的一些岩調
突然丟某種東西出來
那種嚇大家
然後整個市場掉下去
可能就會變成是縱使之地
大家就會去追究你
即便你講的方向
其實是蠻可以理解的
只是一些用詞
大概是這樣
所以稍微的評論一下
這個在市場裡面的事件
希望對大家有所幫助
大概這樣
那這件下我們進去的QA的部分
第一位SCI
嗨夢公子嘎
長照問題除了在制度上也需要改善的地方以外
台灣也需要再更理解生命的重量及尊重
撇除掉特殊的案例難以解決
明明就有AD跟ACP可以預先簽署
那為什麼不好好跟家人討論未來醫療處置的方式
如果只是想用老人家傳統想法難以溝通
覺得所謂的長照安樂死可以解決問題
很像是在逃避問題
溝通的責任不願承擔
卻想要外包至親的生命責任
安樂死不是你安樂讓他死
首先我要先講
我是不知道他前面講的AD跟ACP是什麼
上集跟大家聊完那個話題之後
在YT我有看到一些私訊
就有一些地方的聽眾來做討論
我覺得大家講的也蠻有道理
你要知道因為我們這個節目
我們現在是面對不特定多數人
而且我們聽眾是多達40幾萬以上
這代表說一樣米一樣百樣人
一定會有各自各樣的人
其實有些人的說法我覺得也蠻合理的
首先蠻多人是講說
很感謝我把這樣的一個觀念跟大家分享
因為確實蠻多人的安樂死是安我
然後讓你去死
差不多這樣的一個感覺
只是我也懂得一些地方聽眾的分享
就是說如果說有一些老人家
我一定就看得出來說他們是感情沒那麼好
他就覺得說那是你的身體
我跟你也不好
可是現在你變成是我的負擔
所以是不是如果說你今天財力在某個水準以下
也已經沒有辦法自理
變成是可能家中某一個人的承擔的義務
那這樣子是不是你沒有資格決定自己的生死當然這個東西說出來老實講如果你會覺得非常不合理或是你會認為這個人才是有夠冷血那可能你是在蠻不錯的家庭
就你無法想像這件事情
但我還蠻感謝我自己是在苗栗長大
因為我現在身邊的朋友
都是一群相對富足的人
所以大家的觀念可能都會比較偏向是
就是那種世界大同和平
因為你在一個相對平靜
有資源的家庭長大
你比較不會看到一些社會的陰暗
或是那種為了生存
沒有資源所必須做出的一些取捨
因為我小時候有看過類似的東西
所以我可以理解這些人
為什麼會有這樣的一個說法
我即便可能會覺得說
他實在是有夠惡劣的
這也是你爸媽或什麼
他就跟他爸媽沒有感情
為什麼
所以他有蠻多可以討論的
那種edge cases
就是在極端的案例之下
那一定是有很多的空間
我覺得這也是為什麼
會有一些法官的存在
就是一些那種長照輪輪悲歌
親自把家裡的某個人送下去
然後順便發現說
其實他已經照顧了幾十年了
他一輩子就在這個人身上
他受不了了
他累了
或者說他捨不得
就是那種什麼老母親把自己的
重病的孩子給弄掉
因為他覺得自己快走了
走了這個孩子不知道怎麼辦
那不如就親自讓他下去之類
像這種就是要必須靠
可能就是一些法官
看是怎麼樣
那用一個比較人道的方式去做處理
我只能夠說就是我們每次講很多案例的時候
我覺得最困難一點就是像前面說
因為我們的聽眾太多了
一定有各式各樣的極端的案例
可是我們無法改變的是通力
通力上是你不能夠去幫別人決定
他要生他要死
我知道社會上有可憐的人我知道怎麼樣
就像我說分享一些東西
然後以前在Fresh上面
為什麼後來把Fresh給刪掉
因為我覺得這個平台太多低能額
你要知道低能額是怎麼樣的一個樣子
很簡單
就是他們喜歡用極端的案例去反駁通力
所以不管你講什麼
都會有人可以拿
某一種極端的案例出來講
然後接著就好像說你在亂講
可是那個就是極端的案例
我們也知道世界上有各種極端的案例
可是我們沒有辦法去顧及到太多
就是那種非常Hardcore的東西
我隨便講一個很北藍的律師
因為現在是準備要在日本的飯店要check out
你知道以前我們在飯店在弄的時候
就是跟朋友在經營的時候
你知道在業界有些人是這樣
他會用熱水壺去洗內褲
很屌
就是是什麼樣的
他媽怪小大媽會做
一般都是女生
老大媽他們喜歡用熱水壺
消毒之類的因為這樣子所以我們的房間就全部都不應該放熱水壺還是熱水壺那邊應該要放一個監視器之類的就是你就知道說一定有人會去做一些比較奇怪的事情
可是你沒有辦法為了那個很奇怪的人去改變全部人
就是你還是要去相信
居然多數的社會的人士是良善的
大家不會有一些惡念之類的
算一定會有這樣子的人
所以一定也會有一些私職的父母
私職的真祖父真祖母
你就覺得說罵人
我在你還年輕還強壯的時候
沒有受過你的馈症
你也沒有照顧過我
好像說生的時候就是媽
就是任務就完成了
可能生子都沒有看過你
然後接著你老了我要去照顧你
你會想把它over掉
我覺得也是蠻合理的一件事情
所以我們沒有辦法去討論一些極端的案例
也要去知道就是說
社會上有些那種很苦的人
所以他們有時候講出一些那種極端的東西
就是反應的
就是他的生活過得非常糟糕
我們也沒有辦法幫他什麼
所以就有時候不用把話說得太死
大概是這樣
下面一位全職投資人愛您
下面一位龍夢宮
你好謝謝您的節目
陪伴我從小大一到出社會
讓我從戰士九流美轉變為乖巧指數仔
資產成功累積到八位數
而且睡前聽市場話題還有奇笑
真的是獲益良多
祝夢宮全家平安快樂
諾亞十年後還是愛跟爸爸一起打電動
我跟男友是從顧力熊熊福利那一集開始聽的
今年是我們六周年
上個月男友循著橋虎開市
做了後車廂的求婚
所以你男朋友是做八大是不是
還是那個淘債的
地下金融業
怎麼會用後車廂
後車廂就是那種C300八大仔最喜歡用的
9月29號的生日
請問可以用福利熊的語氣唱
Washabooly
Washabooly every day
亮亮Happy Birthday
不要再玩股票玩到睡不著了
不是吧
這位龍妹妹也蠻厲害的
他說聽我的節目從小大一到出社會
我的節目現在幾年了
2020開始的
現在2026就直接就抓6年好了
所以簡單來說他出社會兩年而已
女生不用擋兵
兩年然後他竟然可以累積到八位數
其實過去的指數是很好沒錯
但是沒有好到這樣
這個應該也是家裡有礦
但恭喜我們不會去酸那種家裡有礦的人
因為我覺得簡單來講就是
像我現在努力的東西
也是希望讓我的兒子家裡有礦
所以我兒子以後就可以起跑點在更上面的地方
父母就是孩子的起跑點
這是沒錯的
所以大家都一起努力
祝你們生日快樂
下面一位Sherry
我是目前在法國商學院就讀過碩士生因為工作了幾年才來念書所以身邊的同學都比我小了很多但我還是非常努力的適應這邊的生活今年8月正式跟男友開始台法遠距離
可以聽聽您對跨國遠距離的想法
男友是個非常認真工作
也受上司青睞的有為青年
也是您的大粉絲
他開車在我的路上都是聽您的Podcast
也跟您在同一間健身房
他說您真的又瘦又帥
那希望夢宮大家可以祝
林口愛斯摩爾的祥祥
9月30號30歲生日快樂
期望祥祥可以繼續在領域中發光發熱
交易報酬大報社
野豬木工業家身體健康平安快樂
首先我還是得講老樣子
我們不會因為說
可能是他聽了一個溫馨的故事
就改變我們的說法
觀念上其實遠距離真的是蠻困難的
遠距離是不好搞的事情
但如果只是一個短暫的遠距離
然後雙方是有非常妥善的未來生涯規劃
或是在人生中的一些安排
已經知道說什麼時候可能會結婚
要有小孩什麼的
我認為遠距離不是一個太大的問題
但因為我們身邊看到蠻多的案例是這樣子
就其實跟很多長輩
我今天早上才看到一篇文章
反正就是在Flash上面人家轉帖
有一個阿伯
然後他就在分享說什麼
他的兒子在美國哪一間念到什麼碩士
他的什麼外甥又在哪裡念到什麼東西
想他年薪多少錢
你知道每次我看到這種我就超想笑
很可憐
就是一把年紀的人
然後再數說自己的小朋友多屌什麼
可是沒有人要回來跟你生活
然後出去就出去
他沒有回來的意思
也不是說什麼人家不能夠在外面
就是去追尋自己的
生命中覺得重要的東西
哪裡有高興
哪裡的生活環境好往那個方向去
無可厚非 大家都會這樣子做
可是就很北蘭
就是你要跟大家分享這個東西
知道幹嘛
你就分享說你很會教育嗎
還是怎麼樣
你教育到孩子都不回來
我知道他不回來不一定是不愛你
這是很奇怪的東西
所以一樣的道理就是
很多搞遠距離的之後會變成說
就一方就不回來了
你不回來你就要去試著把
另外一個接過來
你要有這個心態
如果說沒有
然後想說反正就是且看且走
我先繼續發展看怎麼樣再說
一般這種就結束了
高機率就結束了
一樣不要拿一些Edge cases來跟我講
絕大多數我們看到這樣子
就知道說你就掰掉
所以遠距離也沒有說很難
如果你觀念正確就不難
但是如果說觀念沒有喬好
就超級難
所以觀念正確就是
你們已經選定彼此了
然後接著即便可能兩個人在不同的地方
都沒有見到面
可能還會去面臨各自的同事
同學或什麼的
各自各樣生活中的誘惑
一些有趣好玩的東西
價值觀的衝擊
你都還是知道說
那個人在家裡等你
你也知道你要回家
或是你要把他接過來
我覺得就沒有問題
所以設立一個共同的目標是很重要的
而且要一起往那個目標努力
不要說我設立一個目標
然後接著就只有單一個人
要往那個方向去努力
因為聽起來你們感情不錯
所以你問我意見
我就當然就只能跟你講
我已經這樣包裝了
不要講得太殘酷
不然我覺得遠距離
真的是一個超級難的東西
希望你們可以順利
也感謝你的男朋友的美顏
也希望他在艾斯摩爾可以快樂健康
我看艾斯摩爾在林口好像快蓋好了
蓋一個超大的office在那邊
應該是工廠加office之類的
下面一位
Chere Huang 夢恭您好
五星吹爆
馬上10月就要進入三字頭了
可以跟我說那四個字嗎
你是老鬼
小時候以為考上牙醫系之後
人生就沒有煩惱
長大後的某個timing
到達自己定義的自由之後
好像也沒有過得比較快樂
比較不焦慮
疫情解封至今
也出國旅遊40次左右
有時候也胃同嚼辣
沒有當初的喜悅
雖然遠不及猛攻的1萬分之1
但每週看診路上都有
Chika溫柔的聲音陪伴
各種金句真的是會有良多
超級感謝
最近有人分享生小孩
就是Trading Fund for Joy
我也依然對人生方向出出不前
可以給後輩一個Mission Challenge嗎
像是Kobe當初發起挑戰
期許後輩一樣
我平常不會跟別人分享這些
但猛工真的是我的 role model
祝孟公我老公全家平安
一切順心中秋節快樂
一樣我很常跟大家講說
一個人講的話就會反映出你的狀態
你剛剛前面講的說
Trading fun for joy
我認為不是這樣子
為什麼
因為很多人是這樣
他好不容易賺到錢
就不太會賺錢
好不容易終於有錢
所以他就覺得說我要好好的享樂
要吃要玩
要喝 出國 要殺小的
那是他嘛
因為他就是很匮乏
所以他會覺得他做這些事情
他會爽
我就一直跟大家講
你覺得這樣會爽
你就盡量做
做到你覺得夠了為止
你再去開啟一個新的DLC
這個DLC
這個Downloadable Content
這個新的冒險
支線任務
它不是一個你一定要開啟的東西
我也不是要去宣教
或是告訴人該去做什麼事情
我的觀念還是一樣
干我屁事
你要選什麼他媽的干我屁事但有些真的想知道我的想法我就會告訴你們對我來說或是對你來說你不是也講了嗎你出國思幾次這個是人人稱信的東西
但我懂你
我真的懂你
就是你會覺得不知道要幹嘛嗎
像我現在跑來日本出差
前兩天覺得很新鮮
其實後面像我昨天覺得在找說
有沒有辦法快一點回台灣
你其實心中在想的東西是什麼
一開始就像說我也曾經因為
我跟我老婆很早就結婚
小朋友也算是以台灣的角度來說
我是很早就有小孩
還是媽媽兩個
34歲就是餓寶吧
在我的觀念上
我就曾經也會想過說
如果我在單身一陣子會發生什麼事情
如果我今天獲得自由我會怎麼樣
你會有很多想像
那就跟是你在那老媽床前說
老子今天要幹死你
我就知道要把你幹死
結果你可能一發不到你就累了
躺在那邊喘
所以跪在床腳那邊沒有力氣了
或者是就不知道
就弄到一半 軟掉直接睡覺
很多東西跟你想的是不一樣的
就是你自己會在腦中藝營一大堆嗎
我今天單身我媽出去玩的時候
又怎麼樣
像那時候我去德國看RadioHead的時候
那是我第一次獨履
我老婆不會讓我去獨履的
我是直接發起很大的抗議
因為我真的太喜歡RadioHead
只是沒有想到後來它變成是一個
就他們想說每年就要開好幾個演唱會
日本的我應該也會去
反正總之那時候就想說
這麼多年來第一次
終於要出來辦演唱會
我一定要去
一去就直接看了兩場
連續back to back
超級開心的
我心中在想說我到德國去
我一定會到處走走
我去看一下當地晚上的生活在幹嘛
我不一定要二感
我沒有要做什麼別的事情
可是我就一定會
你知道就一個人自由了
就你知道我在幹嘛
我每天在看玩具
然後就去挑小朋友的玩具
然後接著就累了
結果就回房間
房間睡覺
然後接著等下一場演唱會
就我最後面什麼東西也沒有做
叫Roon Service
躺在飯店裡面
這跟自己想像是不太一樣
就是我很難去形容那種感受
但是我身邊的一些朋友
一些大哥
為什麼我喜歡跟老人家混
對不起
我不是說你們全部都老人家
可是年紀比我大蠻多的
12歲以上
像有一個大哥講的很有道理
他說當你已經習慣跟喜歡上
被需要的感覺
那個是非常有吸引力的
就是你在家裡
你就會覺得自己非常有價值
你一定會想說
媽的你不要再管我了
女人你給我管
傻小孩子我也是養大了
或什麼
你會有這樣的想法
可是你自己出去一次
你不一定會想要當個脫江野馬
因為對你來說
像你前面講的東西
什麼旅遊
很多人跑去吃什麼板錢
還整天
我覺得這樣
就是對於這種生命很有熱愛的人有時候我也是蠻羨慕他們就是他們會覺得這是很酷的東西所以會分享會share可是我就不會覺得這種東西是到底有什麼好share的這超一般的因為錢可以買到的東西太廉價了
現在誰沒有錢
雖然我講這個我知道
又有一些人會覺得
我可能在刺激他或什麼
所以我就說不同階段
你就聽不同階段的我
那想法也會有一些改變
我現在的想法就是
誰沒有錢
每個人都有錢
所以你身邊還在比錢的人超low的
好像有一些那種教育圈的
下也會講說那個誰
11大哥百億大哥
11百億有很屌嗎
其實也沒有多屌
就這樣對不對
其實大家都幾億的人
每個人生活都一樣
都長一樣的
你會想要一直去做一些鋪上消費
那是你嗎
你覺得那樣很爽嗎
你覺得還要去拐年輕妹妹嗎
我不想
我不想要
我覺得那很無聊
因為我玩膩
就是一樣都是吃東西
一樣都是什麼
我都有
出國我也有
我也都是可以不用去考慮預算什麼的
你說這種東西會有放嗎
就不會有放的
放跟Joy會在的
就是你被需要的感覺
你跟你喜歡你愛的人
重新的去體驗童年
這些孩子們
你的童年一些
也不是說你童年一定要過得很差
就是你過去就沒了
你有時候會想要回到小學回到幼稚園
去體驗一下當時的生活
你沒有辦法
可是你跟著孩子就可以
所以沒有孩子就沒有FUN & JOY
在我的角度是這樣
因為前面的東西對我來講
已經是沒有意義了
我再做100次我都不會覺得高興
我覺得像我這次來日本
我做星雨的頭等艙
想說試試看看
一點感覺都沒有
發張照片上傳也沒有
我不是說星雨的服務不好
很好
只是就是就那樣
這拿到什麼東西就那樣
你隨便要掏錢出來
你都可以做到東西
你可以重複做100次的東西
那到底好玩在哪就不好玩了
所以我不認為是
Trading fun for joy
不是這樣
是你到某個時間點
你可能就會覺得生命是很empty
你就想要有一些新的DLC出來
這時候可能就非常適合
但是有趣的是
當一般人到這個時間點
因為不是每個人都是很會賺錢
或是幸運
或是很有甜分
所以可能是等到四五十歲
他才到我瞎的
可能我二十幾歲又到了階段
然後他就會想要有孩子
所以你看到台灣的月子中心
都是一堆10幾歲的在生小孩
然後老來得子超高興的
他們年輕的時候一定講話都很嗆
幹嘛要有這種脫優品什麼的
他就還沒到那個階段
所以還沒到那個階段的人
你跟他多說是無異的
他無法理解
所以你後來越來越懂家裡的一些長輩
雖然有時候他們講話不動聽或什麼的
他說你老了就懂
你年紀慢慢變大
三十幾歲 三十五歲 四十歲
你又開始你老了就懂
你會想跟你朋友講這些
但你只要講這個
就好像以前的老人家
所以你就選擇就不講了
你就好好地感受自己的生活
大概是這樣
所以我不會對你發起一些challenge我只要告訴你其實不要太相信外面的一些說辭因為簡單講你生活過得很好的你沒有空在網路上整天在那邊喇叭大概是這樣
所以你整天在網路上看一下喇叭
你是不會有任何進步的
你只會聽到一些那種還在struggle的
然後好像他媽他懂很多事情
但他一點都不懂
下面一位
JJ小菜雞 孟公安
最近回聽老吉訴
聽到那時GTA6在講到上市
結果搞到競爭才上
想問您炒股
事件交易是不是有受這款遊戲的影響
预计怒阿几岁会碰这款游戏
因为我妈以前都叫我不要玩
现在想想也确实
觉得小朋友没有建设好
帮到这个游戏
可能会跟某个台湾艺人的儿子一样
长大去美国当格雷夫抓不怕
回台湾继续当蓝宝
感觉他讲话很好笑
然后最后祝最近去做天使的奶奶
能够保佑我
还有梦工一家人
谢谢奶奶跨刀保佑我们
非常感谢你
这款游戏跟炒股有什么关系
没有关系
事件交易跟遊戲是沒有什麼影響
但是在Tech2 Interactive這個股票
我是賺錢的
然後我去做波蘭蠢魚
我是賠錢的
然後之前的遊戲舉止事件
我忘記了
那時候應該是沒有獲得什麼收益
就是當時要出那個天堂
所以這個應該跟交易
是沒有什麼太大的關係
那會不會讓諾亞去碰這個遊戲
會耶 我覺得沒有關係
就是當然我知道在GTA裡面
你是非常的自由
你可以開車子
直接把一排人給鏟掉
或是什麼的
其實每個玩GTA
都一定會這樣子玩
不是說每個都會跑去幹大的
去做什麼奇怪的事情
甚至我有一個可能是
unpopular opinion的樣子
就是反我個人的意見
我覺得就是有這些遊戲
讓一些人可以紓壓
所以社會上會少一些時間
你知道嗎
就像是日本的地奧賽上面
有各種超獵奇的那種色情小黃遊
有些是真的那種口味重道
我都會皺眉頭說
這真的有人要搞這個嗎
就是你們這腦袋到底裝什麼東西
可是你不免就會想說
如果你沒有這些東西讓人家去發現的話
他不會做更奇怪的事
所以後來會懂
生命中社會上的一些東西的存在
是有它的意義的
以這種電玩 影視 甚至是修道院的存在
你知道一個說法就是說
因為有這些修道院
所以在每次的生產力爆發的時候
那些incels
就是有些那種仇女的
反正就知道說
有一堆那種年輕男生的地方
如果他們沒事做
因為生產力爆發
所以可能不一定找到工作
閒閒在家之類的
不需要這麼多勞動力
他們沒有辦法去找到地方去
像以前的修道院或像是
〔此段辨識失敗，約 50:00 起〕